if you're working on kubernetes in a
production environment especially on a
larger project or team
you've probably run into namespaces we
haven't talked about them before but
today we changed that
hello caslin
hello caslin hmm cousin
isn't in this room maybe i'll go into
another one
hello caslin oh hi carter what are you
doing here
i came to talk to you about namespaces
but i don't think i could reach you
before
that's kind of ironic actually
namespaces are a tool to keep kubernetes
objects separated as well
if you're in the wrong space you won't
be able to communicate with your objects
i could see that being useful kind of
like how containers allow multiple
applications to share one operating
system
namespaces allow multiple kubernetes
object to share one cluster
right imagining it as a sort of virtual
cluster
makes a lot of sense because a namespace
groups and isolates kubernetes objects
across nodes
and it's not quite as strict as
container isolation
because it's still possible to access
kubernetes objects that are in other
namespaces
that's good to know so a namespace is a
virtual cluster
that's used to make it easier for large
teams to work i've seen these before i
was working on a project where the test
and production objects were in separate
namespaces
sure i've seen that another benefit of
namespaces comes in with setting
permissions
oh yeah i remember the admin set it up
so that only certain people could push a
bill to production
but anyone could push a bill to test
they would have done that using
kubernetes role-based access controls
or rbac using our back an administrator
can give each user a role
which sets their permissions inside a
specific name space
that makes sense so the people on my
team must have had
roles that gave them access to tests but
only a few people had roles that gave
them access to production
right let's talk more about how to set
up the namespaces themselves
we can cover our back or role-based
access controls in a future episode
sounds good to me so how do i get
started using namespaces
technically you already are kubernetes
starts with four
initial name spaces you can check them
out with the cube ctl
get namespace command according to the
docs
cube system is for objects created by
the kubernetes system
cube public is mostly reserved for
cluster usage in case some resources
should be visible and readable publicly
throughout the whole cluster
cube node lease is for the lease objects
associated with each node which improves
the performance of the node heartbeats
as the cluster scales
and the default namespace is for objects
with no other namespace
it's it's like one of those bottom
drawers in the kitchen just throw
anything in there
you can get more info about any of these
namespaces using the cubectl get and
describe commands
for instance you'll see that describing
the default namespace returns something
like this
note that these details show both
resource quota
if present as well as resource limit
ranges
resource quotas and resource limits
resource quota tracks aggregate usage of
resources in the namespace and allows
cluster operators to define hard
resource usage limits that a namespace
may consume
a limit range defines minimum and
maximum constraints
on the amount of resources a single
entity can consume
in a namespace that seems useful if i
need to make sure resource usage is
staying within certain bounds
yep resource quotas and limits are an
important tool for administrators
since namespaces or kubernetes objects i
bet
i can interact with them using the qctl
create and delete commands
yes one thing that's a little different
is that since namespaces hold
other kubernetes objects if you want to
get create
delete or otherwise operate on objects
in a namespace
you must specify that with the dash dash
namespaces flag
it seems like a lot of extra typing but
i guess the shorthand dash
n isn't all that bad we can actually
shorten deployment here to
deploy too there are a lot of convenient
shorthand versions of commands in
kubernetes
that is convenient though it still seems
annoying to have to type the namespace
i'm working into
every command well you're in luck if
you're going to be working out of the
same namespace for a while
there's a way to set cubectl to
automatically use that namespace for all
subsequent cubectl commands
to do that you would use
set context now that sounds handy
so i think that's about it for the
basics you should have just about
everything you need to know to
understand namespaces in case you see
them in the workplace
i think so let me see if i've got this
right a namespace is a virtual cluster
that lets multiple groups of users share
a cluster
each one has its own resources policies
and constraints meaning only people or
objects in my namesakes will see my pods
services and other kubernetes objects
also i can define rules for who can do
what in my name space and
i can enforce how many resources can be
consumed by objects in my namespace
using resource limits and quotas exactly
namespaces are a very useful tool for
everything you just mentioned and more
wow many thanks to caslin for sharing
knowledge about namespaces
for more information about how when and
why to use them
please check out the documentation link
below
you